حصل فصل التخرج هذا العام في
جامعة ماساتشوستس في بوسطن على
أكثر من دبلوماتهم بالأمس ،
فاجأ المتحدث الافتتاحي والرئيس التنفيذي لشركة اتصالات الجرانيت الجرانيت ، روب هيل ، الخريجين ببعض
النقود النقدية الباردة ، ألق نظرة
على أعظم أفراح لدينا في
حياتنا  لقد كانت هدية العطاء ،
لذا فإن كل واحد منكم يحصل على ألف
دولار نقدًا ،
كما ذكرت أنك تحصل على ألف
دولار ، أول 500 هو بالنسبة لك ، إنه
احتفال بكل ما فعلته حتى تكون
هنا اليوم يحتفل قادتك
بالخمسمئة الثانية.  هي هدية تقدمها
إلى شخص أو شخص آخر أو
منظمة أخرى يمكنها استخدامها أكثر مما
أعتقد أن هذا قد يكون الجزء المفضل لدي من
تلك الرسالة ، لذا فإن كل خريج كما
سمعت للتو هناك ممن سار عبر
الولايات حصلوا على اثنين  الأظرف ،
لذا كان لديهم 500 كانت الهدية
كما ترون الآخر المسمى
أعط 2500 طالبًا جامعيًا هناك تلك الهدية التي
بلغت مليوني ونصف المليون
دولار وتقدر فوربس أن هيل لديه خمسة
مليارات دولار ثروة تعمل بشكل جيد معها
نعم في هذا الصدد